I think the more jarring part of it is
how secretive it all was so you watch
your government that claims to be a
democracy and claims to be accountable
to its citizenry through the ballot box
engaging in this indescribably
consequential behavior and purposely
keeping not just the details but the
broad strokes of what they're doing
completely secret from the people who
are supposed to be deciding whether or
not they want their government to be
doing that I mean it's a real subversion
not just a privacy but of democracy
itself and ya know watch it in in in
action essentially in with the
definitive proof of what they're doing
definitely heightened my my skepticism
over the reliability of the US
government's claims the role they play
in the world and its motives as well one
of the most crucial parts of journalism
is to constantly poke and prod at
convention in orthodoxy and she
challenged assumptions that people are
just implicitly accepting not just even
if it makes people uncomfortable but
especially that